large parts of the united states and
canada are experiencing a
heat wave that is shattering countless
high temperature records
one village in canada's british columbia
salt temperatures hit nearly 47 degrees
celsius
at the weekend that's 116 degrees
fahrenheit
that's the highest temperature ever
recorded in canada
[Music]
a cooling dip to beat the summer heat
residents took to the water as the
thermometer rose above 40 degrees
celsius in seattle
for the first time ever
yeah it's hot i mean you just stand
around and you're like i it
you can't breathe it's so hot at least
for me
definitely have to wear shoes yeah yeah
the pavement even grass you're just like
no thank you go back inside
the heat was too much for this farmer's
market
this is very few times that we do close
the market early
most of the time of which we've ever had
to close the market early is because of
snow
and so because of the heat i think this
is the first time we've ever closed
early because of the heat
temperatures like these are no
coincidence
the past decade has been the warmest on
record
and the five hottest days were all
recorded
in the last five years the main thing
going on
is this highly unusual weather pattern
but
that being said climate change is real
our temperatures have warmed here
especially
summer night time temperatures and so
that has
just kind of raised the baseline and
made this
heat event that much more severe while
some seem to revel in the extreme
temperatures
many environmentalists say this heat
wave bears all the hallmarks
of a climate emergency
and for more now i'm joined by david
phillips he is a climatologist he joins
me tonight from toronto the
cool side of canada at the moment
mr phillips it's good to have you on the
program
when you look at these high temperatures
in the the western parts of canada and
the united states
tell me how much of this is extreme
weather
and how much of this is climate change
you know brett it's always the question
that comes up anytime you get a
a monster hurricane a super typhoon a
heat wave or forest fire people always
say is this coming out of our
tailpipes and spokes stacks well you
know i think it's
we know that climate change doesn't
create
heat waves or hurricanes or major storms
but it contributes to it you know these
heat waves
are like our grandparents heat waves
they've occurred before
but what's different about them brett is
the intensity of them the
the statistics of them the character
personality the
nature of these heat waves they're not
all the same this one is much earlier
than we've ever seen before
typically in in western canada uh we see
the warmest temperatures occur at the
end of july the beginning of august
this is in june when it's typically not
the warmest time
we're seeing the areas sprawling from
the arctic circle right down to the
desert southwest and and no escaping it
and with
record breaking and we just broke a
record that stood for 84 years
yeah and um so i think that what climate
change does
is it sort of ramps it up it's sort of
like the steroids for weather and
um and and so therefore it makes uh
systems bigger and badder
and and more impactful and so i think
the degrees or elements of this
heat wave are clearly uh has human dna
but it's not the total cost but as we
move forward if we look into the future
should we be calculating
more heat waves like this to be a part
of the weather
and should we be talking about a new
normal when we talk about
normal weather well clearly
brett i mean there's no question about
it we
what you see is what you're going to get
it's a forecast for the future
and likely we will see breaking
records i mean this records stand for
for one or two more days
or else maybe two years not 84 years
and so my sense is that clearly get used
to it this is the new norm
this is the kind of weather event that
we'll see more often
especially in a country like canada i
mean we're the second coldest country in
the world
we're the snowiest country in the world
people come and ask about wind chill
and polar vortex and and frostbite
it's it's not these these incredible
desert-like temperatures and so for us
where we don't have air conditioning
to speak of in the west or even our
buildings are not set up to
shed the heat uh it's because it's a
real dangerous situation
historically unprecedented but from a
public health point of view
it is uh quite uh quite a hit and so i
think the
the lesson is here uh uh more of them
stronger more intense
hey that is the forecast going ahead and
what's your advice to people
living for example in vancouver or in
the united states in seattle in those
cities
air conditioning has traditionally been
taboo
and now i mean am i right and assuming
it's mainstream you're going to need it
if you want to survive
well i think it's artificial cooling
that is going to clearly be the
uh the the you can't buy an air
conditioner or a fan
in uh in on the west coast of
canada and so that's going to be more
it's going to be
homes are going to be built with
built-in air conditioning i mean
and that of course can make it worse
because it can create more
uh more energy needs and and that could
ramp it up more i mean it's like a
vicious cycle in a way so i i clearly
think people are trying to adjust to it
my best advice is to hey put off today
which you can do
next week i mean it's going to come to
an end but
clearly the people who are most affected
by this are the elderly infants that
don't perspire uh as well and they have
poor circulation
the homeless people we're already seeing
uh
cooling centers uh are are opening
longer and hydrating centers uh
even industry is closing down because of
the the heat of the day
so it's something that is just not
factored into our
our plans and our strategies but it's
going to have to be going ahead this is
a
lesson to to learn this is not something
that is just a one-off
it's going to be something that's going
to be very much part of
of the new climate here in uh in canada
yeah the 21st century climate definitely
not 20th century
anymore mr david phillips senior
climatologist for environment and
climate change
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you brad
you